hello everyone
and thank you for joining us for chapter
two in our four-part series
on transforming healthcare into health
creation
today's presentation is titled chapter
two
redefining lab operational and clinical
excellence
and it's presented by jeremy schubert
divisional vp
uso commercial operations at abbott
diagnostics
and also joining us is dr joshua hayden
chief of chemistry
at norton healthcare i am christy jewell
of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labradood sponsored
by abbott diagnostics for more
information on our sponsor
please click on the abbott logo on the
left side of your screen
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits i would now like
to introduce to you today's speaker
jeremy schubert divisional vp uso
commercial operations at abbott
diagnostics
and dr joshua hayden chief of chemistry
at norton healthcare for complete
biographies
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen gentlemen you
may now begin
your presentations thanks christy and
good morning and good afternoon to all
of my laboratory amigos that are out
there
i hope everybody's staying safe you know
throughout this process
we want to start today by just saying
thank you to to everybody on this call
and all those will be listening later
from a laboratory perspective
uh we all know being in the lab business
that
the laboratory is the unsung hero in
healthcare we are the decision engine
that really
makes it go and unfortunately there's
not a lot
of recognition for that however
nothing has has like this crisis
has has heightened the attention to just
how important
diagnostics is and the work you guys are
doing out there every day
to flatten the curve to keep our
community safe
is extremely valuable and we can't thank
everybody enough
and appreciate everybody enough for the
great work that you're doing each day
to facilitate uh getting through this
crisis and actually creating healthier
communities on the other side of it
as i've shared with my team you know all
these crisis
crises as they happen they do one of two
things they either strengthen
or they weaken and this is an
opportunity for the lab
industry for all laboratories to
strengthen to this process
and to demonstrate their real uh
contribution to
the health and well-being of their
community so thank you uh what i'm going
to do guys i'm going to give you
today is a kind of a quick recap of what
we talked about
in chapter one around the kind of the
future of health care what's driving it
and then dr hayes is going to talk a
little bit about how we use the data
that we have and take a really new turn
on this concept of more with less and
and what the laboratory's role can be in
that
and i'll take a quick summary at the end
so let's begin with it with with
what we talked about last time and i'm
going to break this up into three
components
one is just how quality has been
redefined
to what is health creation and what does
that mean
and three what is the environment what
are the environmental factors that we
have to consider
from a lab leadership perspective to be
able to make massive impact
and i'm going to start with a slide
about my good friend michael ela for
those of you on the last call you know
this is the ceo of nokia
and his famous statement about we didn't
do anything wrong but somehow he lost
again the central theme here that we
have to carry through
is this is not about doing something
wrong it's about ensuring that we're
doing the next
right thing that we're preparing for
what's next that we're developing new
skills
new competencies new new processes that
facilitate
forward movement in healthcare it's not
enough just to do a good job
we always have to be considering how
we're getting better how we're
developing and how we're preparing for
what's next
and that the last time we talked a
little bit about how health care
was changing and why and we re round
time back to the year 2013
where in fact actually in the us medical
error
was the third leading cause of death and
our essential theme here was not that
our u.s health care system's bad
because it's not but what it was a
central theme is that we can do
better there are things that happen
that are diagnostic errors that are just
general error in
our error in general that are impacting
patients in a negative way
and so what this was is a call to action
for us to rethink what we were doing as
a health system
redefine what quality is and for the
for everyone with all the constituents
within the health system to take a step
forward to change
to develop and to grow and so that
actually spurred my first point that we
have to carry forward from last
last time which is the metrics that we
should be looking at the things that we
should use to assess
how good we're doing are not turnaround
time
and they're not cost per test they're
centered around the cms metrics that
were developed
into after 2013 because of this
medical error impact to the leading
cause of death and it centers on things
that are important to the patient
and the call to action from a laboratory
perspective is that we need to align
our thinking and our contribution to how
we affect metrics like length of stay
like readmission rate like uh you know
hospital acquired conditions
those are the things that we have to
think about the role we play because
if we do not play a significant role in
moving those metrics in a positive
direction
then we are not relevant it doesn't
matter that we
create most of the data that's used from
a from a
medical decision making perspective if
we're not facilitating good decisions on
the other side
we're not going to be relevant the
second topic that we started to approach
was how health is changing and the
central hypothesis here is this is going
to move from health care to health
creation
no one is going to expect to be treated
treated from an acute
a chronic or even a preventative
perspective
people want to be treated as a whole
person so health systems are going to
have to redefine
how their approach to be more holistic
and cover the entire life course of a
person
by the same token we talked about how
you can learn more about a person's
health
in their prognostics from their zip code
than their genetic code and so social
determinants are going to
become an ever growing and increasing
element to what we have to consider in
how we treat patients
we also talked last time about the fact
that it wasn't about personalization it
was about engagement
for sure personalization enables
engagement but personalization
in and of itself is not sufficient for a
healthcare system to advance
so part of what we have to think about
is how do we participate
in a world where the laboratory can
bring strength to patient engagement
and finally the thing we have to prepare
for is the fact
that people are not going to want to
experience health care in the
traditional sense
they're going to want to see it
integrated into their daily lives
now this is going to be actually
accelerated from since the last time we
we talked because you can imagine with
this covid crisis
this is going to facilitate a new need
for people to want to experience
care without having to go to a facility
to experience it
this this crisis is actually going to
accelerate a change in telemedicine
this crisis is going to accelerate a
change in alternative care models
a change in triaging of patients before
they get to the hospital host of other
things that are gonna
that are gonna happen simply accelerated
by this crisis but it's gonna fit
into this domain of the fact that people
want it integrated into their daily
lives
the final topic that we hit on was kind
of this construct of okay well how does
that work
and you know and trying to think
differently than just hey we have our
health
our health system because we actually
have two other components that we have
to figure out how do we integrate
and align with when you think about the
social determinants you have all these
community resources that are there to
support the well-being of the population
of the community
and then you have this concept of the
home and what really is the daily life
of people and the question really is is
how do we connect all of these things
how do we make them work in concert and
effectively how do you create health
care without walls
again not having the foresight of the of
the cova crisis
but this is exactly what is stressing
our system right now
is how could we manage patients
who are self-quarantined in a way where
kind of healthcare becomes wi-fi around
them
and if you think about if we already
were at this point where we could
coordinate all these resources
we would be much more effective at
dealing with this crisis
because again what we'd be able to do is
is
deal with patients as they self
quarantine at home and mobilize all the
community resources to support them
so the sense of isolation the sense of
fear could go away because the sense of
support
would be there unfortunately this
doesn't exist today
and and why that doesn't exist is simply
because
as you see on the slide here is these
there needs to be connective points
bridges that connect this external data
into the health system
and then bridging from the health system
to the home
into the daily life of individuals if
these bridges existed we would be in a
much better position
to react and so the whole central theme
of that was just this
that from a lab perspective it's not
sufficient
for us to measure the future around
automation
automation's going to be important it's
going to be necessary
but it is not who we are the future of
lab medicine
is going to be measured by our ability
each of us
to step in and take a leadership role in
the decision making that happens
in the clinical pathway strategically
operationally not just within the four
walls of the system
but in a system without walls and so
what we postulated in the last round
was you know there are five things that
you know that
steps that laboratories should be taking
to facilitate
developing competency and capability in
this which we're not going to review
today
but as we go back into the covet crisis
i want to bring back my good friend
mr elop okay now again as we kind of
approach this
we have to be thinking about um is we're
going to look back at some point at this
crisis
and it's going to teach us some very
valuable lessons about what we could
have done differently to be ready
what we could have done differently to
be empowered and
this is also an excellent opportunity
for us to educate the broader health
community
about the value of the lab because as we
all know
lab medicine should be the leader in
this crisis
and there's a number of of of scientific
publications that walk through
pandemic and epidemic after pandemic
after epidemic
and walk through the the role the
laboratory should play the role
diagnostics should play
and as this highlights in in this
article
that you know clearly that the
diagnostics is fundamental to the
approach
and it actually highlights the fact that
there are developmental needs that need
to take place
from a diagnostic network perspective
for us to be
effective at dealing with pandemics and
epidemics
and that's not development of new
technologies that's not just the
development of informatics
it includes people and process in
addition to technology
it's important and as
the organization find kind of laid out
it's not just that we're
when when we're at the heat of of
of the crisis the diagnostic plays a
role there's a surveillance front end
and back end that's really really
important so at some point
this could very easily die away as we
get new tests out for cobit
that the people go okay well now we can
do testing diagnostics fades to the back
that's that can't be the case in fact
on the on the post surveillance side we
have a big role to play
and we need to be prepared to play it
and being prepared for
a future element or a future emergence
of a new infectious disease
of how we would manage that and so
staying on top
of changes that we need to make in our
operating model are going to be really
essential
in the end it all boils down to the fact
that an accurate diagnosis
is the first step to getting effective
treatment the world health organization
knows that
healthcare knows that and we're at the
center point
of it and so part of our our job has to
be how do we use the available resources
and tools and data that's what dr
hayes is going to talk about to help us
get to that accurate diagnosis
faster and more efficiently at the end
of the day
the things that you i would encourage
you to think about as we go through the
rest of this presentation is the
following
is there's there is there is a scale
of value of impact that you make
as as a laboratory right and from the
basic level of
of business continuity of operating of
operations of turnaround time and cost
per test
yeah that's that's that's that's
important and essential
but it's low impact to the overall
health system but as we move up to the
hospital and the system level
really focusing on their kpis and
putting ourselves in a position
of affecting turner affecting
readmission rates and length of stay
that's where we start to create value
and if we build a system and a model
that helps us and no matter what disease
burden it is because it doesn't have to
be infectious disease
where we're really understanding and
being able to anticipate shifts in the
population
deal with crises as they come and handle
the post surveillance so we can learn
and grow and develop and get stronger as
health systems that's where labs create
maximum impact and to do that
if you have no tools right that's a
challenge if you have tools that sit in
the emr
that gets you somewhere but that doesn't
really enable you to be the best of who
you
are make your maximum contribution and
so this is about
making sure from a lab perspective
there's a dedicated strategy
and control of the tools and the
processes that enable
this type of analysis insight
development and deployment to occur and
so
that's why i'm excited to turn it over
to dr hayden who's going to talk a
little more about
this concept of more with less from a
different angle and show us
his thoughts and how to apply this this
type of thinking
in vivo dr hayden
thank you very much jeremy um
and yeah i'm happy that everyone was
able to to take the time
to to join us today i think it shows
maybe
one of two things either one you're a
chemist like me which means it's your
microbiology colleagues who are running
around crazy trying to figure this out
or hopefully it means two you recognize
that we're going to get through
this challenging time and we can't lose
sight of doing those important
long-term things which are going to make
us so much better
6 12 18 30 months from now
and i think keeping that eye on the
long-term goals and
strategically moving forward is really
really important
so thank you all for coming and as here
we said we're going to be talking a
little bit more about
doing more impactful testing with less
waste
just for disclosure support for this
program is provided by abbott
and i am presenting at the request of
abbott
so some of you might not be familiar
with norton healthcare
so norton healthcare is situated in the
louisville kentucky area
although our primary service area is
about 16 counties
with about one and a half million people
with almost three quarters of our
patients coming from the jefferson
county
area and we have a range of health
conditions which are
impacting the health of our communities
and these health conditions then become
our areas of priority
these are areas where we want to focus
additional efforts
not surprisingly heart disease cancer
diabetes are at the top
we also have norton children's hospital
and so children's health
is always an essential area of priority
for our health system and in case you
aren't too
familiar or you're still not terribly
interested
in what norton healthcare does i will
mention
that our system of five hospitals seven
cancer center infusion labs and
dozens of norton medical group and icc
areas
also cover the louisville area
which accounts for the vast majority of
the world's bourbon
so in case you're like me and you often
find yourself needing to go home and get
a drink
at the end of the days recently remember
we're
helping to keep keep that bourbon
distilling
one of the things that i've really liked
about norton
is that as a system we've tried to focus
on doing more for the health of our
communities
i think one good example of this would
be our flu tracker
so norton started this some time back we
put it up on the website to allow
people to go in and see the
cases of diagnosed influenza
a or b per certain number of residents
in their geographic area right so why do
we do this
well because as we're all learning
understanding
where communicable diseases are highly
prevalent
is an essential step to reducing the
spread
of those diseases i certainly appreciate
it because it helps me see where i might
maybe not want to go to a to a child's
birthday party for instance
but i want to mention that when we're
looking at this data
the only reason we're able to display
this in an effort to help
our community health is because it's
built around
essential accurate diagnostics
right this is the sort of communicable
disease tracker that would be fantastic
to have when we have these
new outbreaks such as covid
unfortunately we don't have those
essential diagnostics
and without that key first step as
jeremy mentioned
you can't take any of the subsequent
steps
it's also why i think that doing
molecular flu
like we do at all of our hospitals and
all of our medical group offices
is an important and worthwhile activity
yes it is substantially more expensive
but i believe that that expense is worth
it given the value and
accuracy of that result because i think
that molecular flu
is a great example of us doing
impactful testing which is really what
we want to be doing more of
so what is impactful testing
so i took a stab at a definition of that
i would consider impactful testing a
laboratory test
that is required for and leads to
improved patient care and it's really
those two elements
required for and leads to right
so required for we do a lot of testing
where the patient's care path is going
to go
regardless of what that result came back
as
and that's not impactful testing
furthermore the laboratory test has to
actually
lead to improved patient care right so
jeremy was talking about medical errors
being the third leading cause of death
you know one thing that we've learned
one of the most common laboratory
medical errors
is a failure to retrieve error that
means that there is
some essential laboratory test out there
in the patient's record very often the
electronic
medical record which is never retrieved
never acted on
and because of the failure to retrieve
and act on that result
patient suffers harm right so impactful
testing needs to think about
how can you ensure that appropriate
patient care and next steps
are actually taken
so what is an example of impactful
testing which i think we've been
able to do here at norton
so one example would be hiv testing
so for those who might not be as
familiar
there's 1.1 million people in the united
states
who have been diagnosed with hiv
now out of that just over a million
individuals
it's estimated that one in seven
are undiagnosed they're unaware of their
hiv positive
status studies have shown
that those undiagnosed individuals
account for eighty percent or more
of the new infections right
so think about that one in seven
individuals a minority
of those living with hiv are undiagnosed
and yet that small percentage of
individuals accounts for the vast
majority of new infections
with estimates showing that every
hundred undiagnosed cases of hiv
leads to eight new infections
so if we can actually test for and
diagnose people with hiv
that is a very impactful testing because
not only can we alter the care pathway
of that individual who was previously
undiagnosed
but we can also reduce the risk of them
spreading it to
others and creating new cases
this is why the u.s preventative
services task force actually
put out a recommendation that
individuals between the ages of 15 to 65
years of age
be screened for hiv regardless of
risk factors
so one of the things we wanted to do at
norton was to say
how good a job are we actually doing
screening individuals for hiv
and i want to recognize here the
tremendous work by the sdi task force
led by michelle rose who put together
this data
and have been influential in the efforts
i'm about to talk about
so when michelle and her team looked at
the patients that we were actually
testing
what they found was that about
three-quarters of the individuals tested
were women even though men accounted
for three-quarters of our positive
results
so once again a quarter of the patients
were actually testing are men
but out of that small percentage who are
tested they account for the majority
of new positive cases and this was a
strong indication to us
that while we were doing a better job
screening women especially
in collaboration with our ob gyn
colleagues
we were missing a lot of individuals who
should be tested
and so we set about to implement
universal screening
so how do we set up our hiv universal
screening
well the first thing that we did is we
called it an opt-out
program right this is not that
individuals
choose to be screened it's that
individuals
have a choice to not be screened and
that language is
really important when your frontline
providers are
discussing with patients whether or not
they want to be screened
right telling them that everyone is
being screened unless they object
people are far less likely to object
so to implement this we actually build a
best practice
advisory recommendation in the epic
emr and you can see that hiv screening
comes up
as part of your general assessment and
triage
of an individual and if the patient does
not
opt out then the lab tests will be done
automatically so what impact did this
have
in the norton system
well we implemented the universal
screening
round about september and you can see
right away
that our volume of testing increased
substantially right
we started to use a lot more hiv test
reagents
and the lab budgets were certainly
impacted
and i think this is an important thing
to remember that
there is certainly a cost associated
sometimes with doing
more testing but i think we need to ask
ourselves
first of all are we doing more impactful
testing the cost of the test itself
is trivial compared to the cost of
undiagnosed
untreated hiv i'm not however
so naive to think that cost isn't a
consideration
but we need to remember that in addition
to costs
there are charges and revenue and so
with hiv for instance medicare part b
reimburses for hiv screening
i listed the the dollar amount from the
recent fee schedule though obviously
that can
vary by area and medicare part b
will cover this once per year if you're
15 to 65
or younger than 15 older than 65 and at
increased risk for hiv
right so we build up our recommendations
for universal screening to be consistent
with these reimbursement guidelines
now certainly uninsured individuals
are a different matter but
studies have shown that medicare
medicaid individuals account for sixty
percent of our er visits
with private insurance who almost always
follows medicare recommendations
counting for thirty percent so ninety
percent of our patients
are actually going to have coverage for
this
testing but again that's just the
financial
aspect what about the clinical aspects
when we implemented the universal
screening we ended up
in the following months diagnosing seven
new cases of hiv through universal
screening
in our emergency department these were
seven individuals who were unaware of
their hiv status
who were only discovered and diagnosed
thanks to
universal screening in the emergency
department
so going through some of these cases you
know one thing i want to mention
is hiv is a communicable disease
and while it is associated with certain
risk factors
it doesn't discriminate in any way
so certainly what we are seeing is that
the rise of iv
drug use as a consequence of the opioid
epidemic
is fueling an increase in some of these
blood-borne pathogens
hiv-hcv and we see that here with a high
prevalence of iv drug use
however even non-drug using heterosexual
individuals
are susceptible to contracting hiv
i also wanted to point out that we had
two cases
of acute hiv diagnosed
and i want to point this out because one
it's an opportunity to talk a little
more about how we do our hiv testing
and the time course of the disease but
also because it's important to remember
it's not just about doing testing it's
about doing the right testing
so the cdc recommends doing a laboratory
based
4th gen antibody antigen combo assay
which is what we use at norton but that
doesn't mean that everyone is using that
individuals are still using third gen
hiv assays
which would only detect the antibodies
and would have actually missed
these cases so why is that
well if we look at the time course of
hiv in relation to hiv testing
we have infection which we can define as
t0
and then there is a window period
during which you're unable to detect the
disease
and that window period varies based on
the nature of the testing
that you're doing so early on after
infection
you can see you have the rapid rise in
hiv rna
is hiv is proliferating unchecked the
human body hasn't mounted any immune
response
we actually see large decreases
in the cd4 count and patients at this
point can reach
levels of hiv viral load and low cd4
counts
that they will not see again until the
terminal phases
of the disease you then have
a rise in the hiv p24 antigen
and in this area where we have the low
cd4 high viral load and
p24 present this is what we call the
acute hiv
phase then we do start to mount
serologic response with igm followed by
igg with zero conversion in one to three
months
and the viral load starts to go down cd4
counts actually
bounce back up right so being able to
detect patients in this
acute hiv window is very important
because that's when they're actually
symptomatic and are more likely to
present
to a health system for treatment
and so you have an increased likelihood
of detecting
these individuals in addition because of
the high viral load
they tend to be more infectious during
this acute
hiv period and so it's essential if
you're going to be offering hiv testing
that you're following cdc
recommendations and offering
a 4th gen hiv antibody antigen
combo
beyond the seven cases of new
hiv that we detected we also had an
individual
with known diagnosis of hiv who wasn't
linked to care and i want to talk about
this because
if you remember i defined impactful
testing in part by testing that leads to
improved patient care
i know of medical centers who have
implemented universal screening
and have not seen that essential linkage
to care
and if all you're going to do is do a
lot of hiv testing and not have someone
follow up on those results
connect the patients to care help them
address whatever barriers to care
might exist then you're not necessarily
doing
impactful testing right
but of course you can't link patients to
care
if you don't know that they need linked
right and that's really
what we're talking about doing with
impactful testing
it's making the clinical laboratory an
important
link in the chain from patients to the
care they need
so in the case of our hiv universal
screening we're talking about
patients being tested in the emergency
department
the laboratory producing accurate
results
and then nurse navigators being around
to do a tremendous job
reaching out to those patients
connecting them to care helping them
through the psychological
emotional socioeconomic and health
challenges
that they're about to face to ensure
that those patients
get the care that they need
and i really think that that's what
impactful
testing does it makes us a link in the
chain
in order to do that we do have to ensure
that our test results
are accurate and we have to help spur
necessary clinical action
and a lot of times that requires us
getting out of our little laboratory
silos
and actually going and speaking with
people too often i see situations where
some of the things we do in the
laboratory we think
we're properly informing or educating
and maybe we're not doing nearly as good
a job of it
as we think we are right and so to
change gears a bit here
i think a good example of of that is
when we
think about some of the interferences
and limitations
of our assays right so with your hiv
you should be doing a fourth gen if
you're not doing a fourth gen what are
you doing to ensure your providers
know the limitations of the third gen
or let's take drug interferences as an
example
so here i look i will use full vistrent
phasladex as an example so fulvestrine
has come out
as a treatment for estrogen receptor
positive metastatic breast cancer
it works by competing with esther dial
for hormone receptor binding and that
prevents the the driver of
cancer cell growth and
division the problem of course
is that one essential laboratory test
in patients with estrogen receptor
positive metastatic breast cancer is
actually
checking levels of ester diol
and that can get problematic because as
you might be able to see
from the chemical structures shown here
vulva strength works by being an ester
dial
analog it structurally is very similar
to ester diol
and that structural similarity is what
allows it to work
and interfere with hormone receptor
binding but it also allows it
to interfere with the antibody based
amino
acids many of us use for ester diol
and so for this reason there have
actually been
disclaimers out there about the
fulvestri interference
and estradiol measurements and the
impact that they can have
to patient care right and so this impact
can vary
from risk of unnecessary therapy
modification um to surgical intervention
which is unnecessary
so what do we as labs do
about this potential interference or
let's go a step further right what does
what do our vendors do
about these potential interferences
so what most vendors do and
i'm not picking on on abbott or the
alinity platform here right
but this is an excerpt from their
instruction for use
and they put a disclaimer that the assay
should not be used to assess
esther dial levels for patients
undergoing fulvic
treatment an alternative method should
be used
and i can tell you this is how every
manufacturer in the u.s
currently handles these sorts of
interferences
so does anybody here think your
clinicians spend
a lot of time reading the package
inserts
from your manufacturer i mean maybe a
better question is
how many of us spend as much time as we
should spend
reading package inserts from
manufacturers
right and even when we do read it
our response is rarely much better than
putting something
in an ifu right what we do is we put
some sort of information on a comment
which is appended to every result
right how many folks here have seen what
the comments
look like so what i'm showing here
is an example of the visibility of our
comments
with one of the commonly used epic views
and so what you're looking at is a
snapshot
with some laboratory results and
anything which is
in italic with a little asterisk
actually has a comment and so
triglycerides for instance
has a little comment telling people what
desirable
what borderline high high and very high
triglyceride levels actually are
fascinating reading i'm sure the tsh for
instance
in this particular example this was
taken some time back
our lab is using a method that has a
biotin interference
and so we're putting an interference
that this result may be inaccurate if
the patient's taking biotin
now those two comments from a patient
care standpoint
are very very different right the
physician probably
already knows what a desirable or
undesirable triglyceride level
is they may or may not know
about inaccurate results due to biotin
but in our current emr these are
displayed
exactly the same
and as a complete a side note i'm also
going to say this these triglyceride
comments and the cholesterol comments
it's
it's always irksome to me right when we
post something like a triglyceride level
of 120
and then we append this long comment
that tells them
what it would mean if the triglyceride
was under 150 or what it would mean if
it was greater than 500 right
if we know what the value is why
shouldn't our comments be a little more
tailored
to what that specific result we're
reporting means
not what the realm of possible results
could possibly mean
right regardless i'm not sure how much
it matters right because you can see
these comments
aren't terribly visible right our
clinicians do an amazing job
looking through them because our
clinicians try very hard to do what they
can
for best patient care but eventually you
get tired
right and i think labs need to start to
think is there a better way for us
to handle this whenever someone tells me
that their lab handled something by
putting a comment
my mind always goes to the to the
simpsons
there's a great episode where
bart has fallen down a well and town of
springfield decides they can't ever risk
that
happening again right this is like when
you find out about a patient safety
event because somebody misinterpreted a
lab and so you put a comment
and then we think oh that'll fix it and
so what's
what springfield did was have
groundskeeper willie go
and pound the sign that says caution
well up
and you can see it's in front of the
well which has
360 degree access and groundskeeper
willie thinks that should do it
and that's what i always think this is
maybe making us feel good but are we
really actually helping patients right
because what we need to do is
selectively in a targeted
manner intervened to share the
information which is
needed for clinicians to get their
patients
on the best possible care pathway
and what i'm talking about of course
really is clinical decision
support right cds so how would that look
for something like
fulvestrin right well the idea is that
cdf
could allow labs to prevent the release
of results for patients with known
interference right
so when we have our provider taking a
look at her patient
wanting to measure a lab right
all of that is data the medications the
patient's on
the the lab order and that can all flow
in through a clinical decision support
tool
which could notify the lab or even
notify the clinician
directly i think in my mind ideally it's
the lab so we can have a conversation
right
and we can let them know this test you
ordered
on this patient who's receiving this
medication
shouldn't be done and we're going to
help you we're going to send this out to
a reference laboratory
doing a different methodology such as
tandem mass spectrometry
and i think this is where we really need
to start going
to ensure more impactful care
you know jeremy had that great slide
where he
where he talked about sort of the the
bridges and i think for
too long we've required the doctor to be
the only bridge
connecting this and the reality is
that's just not
feasible anymore they can't know all of
the
interferences that we have and i don't
believe that the current
methods we have for highlighting those
interferences in the emrs
are actually working
and implementing something like cds can
help ensure
that we offer more impactful testing
and this is once again it's making the
laboratory an
important link in the chain and keeping
our patients
safe because really
when we think about the doctor having to
act as that
bridge right it's simply too much and
that's why folks have talked about
healthcare moving from ignorance to
ineptitude
and i i don't mean ignorance or
ineptitude in a negative manner as i
said we have a lot of well-meaning
individuals doing the best
best they can but the scope of human
knowledge has simply
expanded to the point where we have far
too many patients
being hurt because of a failure to apply
known knowledge so actually this
this picture here is talking about
mercury
um and how it was earlier thought to
possibly be a
a therapeutic for syphilis right
and it's easy to to think about these
crazy things that
that medicine used to do and and wonder
how they ever got that idea
but the reality is that was a time when
ignorance prevailed we simply
didn't know how to treat syphilis
right but they were doing the best they
could seeking out whatever knowledge was
there
now we're in a situation where the
amount of
knowledge which is out there far exceeds
the capacity of the human brain to
retain it
all right and so i think that we need to
start to
provide a little more help and guidance
and of course
providing help and guidance starts in
the pre-analytic mode right it's
ordering the right tests right and we
can do that through a range of options
so some of the
the best practice advisories right we
talked about what we did with
the hiv opt-out screening the universal
screening
this is an example looking at hepatitis
c screening
from a published paper but i'm going to
mention that
each one of these sort of you know
pop-ups and best practices
these all take a tremendous amount of
time
and you're doing it on a case-by-case
basis and you quickly
overload your practitioners right
and i don't believe that we only have
the single isolated incidents
where this is necessary i actually think
that there's a lot of missed
opportunities
for testing so if we just go back to
sexually transmitted infections sdi
testing
one thing i looked at was the nature of
the testing coming out of our lab
looking at
hiv hcv and syphilis testing
and these venn diagrams are showing the
numbers
for how many times did we only have an
hiv test
956 how many times did we have an hiv
a syphilis and an hcv 1531.
we had 224 isolated syphilis tests
right now i'm not saying that there
aren't reasons why you might only want
one or two of these right
but it does mean that we need to think
about in general
what sort of sti testing should every
patient be getting
and are we making that easier for our
clinicians
to order because when we have
298 patients only getting hiv
and hcv are we possibly missing
syphilis in those 298 patients
and when we get the right tests ordered
right then we have to think about how
that impacts the patient
so going back to the paper which had
looked at
increasing orders for hcv you know what
they found was that
they were able to detect 53 new cases
of hcv but out of that 53
only 18 actually reached therapeutic
goals right and so on one hand that's
great
because you have 18 patients who
wouldn't have reached therapeutic goals
without the testing on the other hand
that means that you have
35 patients who were diagnosed as
positive
where no clinical action was taken right
that's not impactful testing because the
patient
care pathway was not improved
i think i've been thinking a lot about
sti testing because
really this is an area where the
community as a whole
has to think about where we're going to
do this testing how we make sure
that all of these patients testing
positive or at least a greater
percentage of them
are referred on to the proper care
pathways
right and so norton for instance uh
operates on a hub and spoke model and so
we're thinking about
where does id serology fit into the hub
and spoke model
for clinical laboratories financially
it's best for us to centralize
all of this but is that best for
ensuring that patients get on the right
care pathway
do we need to have this sti testing
available
at every one of the spokes in our health
system
and no that doesn't make the best
financial sense
right but i also think that we need to
not fall into the trap of commoditizing
ourselves right because when you start
to make the lab a commodity
then you get traded away right and we
all know
the challenges we face with pama coming
but we also know that when all you're
doing is generating lab results
for the lowest amount of money possible
then you are going to face pressures and
you're going to be bought out
and it's happening all around our area
and all around the country there's
larger labs exercise economy of scale
larger labs you can think about what
makes the most sense financially
not necessarily thinking what makes the
most sense for the patients at this
health system and that's where i think
we need to to resist this
yes we need to be good stewards of our
resources but we also need to think
about using our resources
to provide value to our health system
and our patients
and we do that through more impactful
testing and so with that i'll
turn it back over to jeremy before we
take
some more questions awesome thank you so
much
dr hayden so just kind of as a as a
quick recap
you know a lot of great content and kind
of perspective and application that dr
hayden has shared
and it centers along the lines of how do
we think about
the role of the lab and how the lab can
create value
i encourage all of us as we're kind of
going through this you know to challenge
ourselves to move beyond
the the concept of just automation
turnaround time
cost per test and move into as dr
hayden's outlined in his examples ways
that we could
uh impact uh the bigger picture whether
that's
uh remiss rates and length of stay all
the way to is
he rightfully highlighted just taking
some actions that can
impact the population health with hiv
all
great applications of leveraging the lab
to create
bigger value both clinically and
financially for the health system
at large and for the community and as it
kind of
outlined you know there's a way of
thinking about this of
kind of what control you have and and he
and he artfully shared
kind of even in worlds where we think
the emr
is meant to play this role it's going to
do this for us
at best it's an average impact because
of
how the how it's structured because how
comments reflected i'm not sure how many
of us have actually
been able to see the clinical lens of
the emr but there's a reason why so many
physicians have pop-up fatigue and
burnout
because of what's coming at them and
instead of trying to put more through
the emr
you know the really challenge for us is
how do we have more control and take
more of a personalized approach
an active approach in working side by
side with clinicians
and stepping in to that that patient
situation
and facilitating better decision making
better outcomes and the like i think dr
hayden expressed that
really well and it kind of stays in line
with this
this multiple demo domains of things
that labs can consider
and as we shared last time you know
there's a there's a number of ways
to kind of approach at this but you know
one of the best steps is to actually
start just by taking
an assessment whether you do it
yourselves or you get some
outside help there's a number of tools
that are available for assessing kind of
the situation and figuring out and
determining what's the best way
to align what you want to do as a
laboratory what you can do as a
laboratory
to what your community and your health
system at large needs
and and that really is a a different set
of activities and thinking
then maybe we get the opportunity to go
through
on a day in day out basis so it all kind
of starts with assessing and building a
strategy for it
um one thing i did want to highlight for
our customers that are they're out there
from a coveted perspective just as an
aside
and for anyone who's actually interested
um you know we're working through
a number of things to try to help our
customers through this crisis
and this more centers on business
continuity but just as
more of a public service announcement if
you're an avid customer there's
there's a number of things we have going
on to try to facilitate
helping business continuity both from a
supply and service perspective
um and i would encourage you to reach
out to your a representative to be able
to participate
in either you know virtual huddle with
your team and then we're doing a number
of regional
and national calls to facilitate best
practice sharing
understanding kind of local incidents
and prevalence and being able to manage
through and helping everybody support
each other through this process
we were talking before the call began
it's just how important it is
that we all help each other out um and
we're setting up some mechanisms to
enable that to happen from a lab
community perspective and
anyone who wants to participate or wants
more information for that you know feel
free to reach out
to our representatives or to us directly
so that being said guys
um you know we'll we'll we'll take some
um
you know questions from the audience
christy
thank you jeremy and thank you dr hayden
for joining us and for your informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and to our audience if you have any
questions you'd like to ask and have not
done so yet please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started jeremy let's
start with you can you expand defining
prognosis
based on zip code instead of genetic
code
yeah sure so so in the e you know the
foundation
of the social determinants of health you
know you can learn a lot
about uh someone's of someone's ability
someone's health and someone's ability
to
uh manage their health health literacy
and otherwise
based off of kind of where they live uh
there's a number of studies
that are out there but whether you live
in a community that has a
high poverty rate a community that has
uh
you know a a severe uh incidence of
pollution
a number of things that can factor that
all the way back into there's even
studies that i've read back in my mph
days
of you know people who were who grew up
in blue collar homes or single fathers
uh you know had different had different
outcomes
as it related to their health and
well-being not just physically
but also emotionally and so i share that
to say
that as you even as you approach any
kind of disease burden that you have
being able to understand the dynamics
the social dynamics
surrounding a given population
can facilitate better insight for how to
treat them
and more specifically in some of these
disease burdens if you can understand
the zip codes in your population a
little bit better
uh what you can do is be a lot more
proactive
in your approach not only with
clinicians
but also with the patients or the people
directly and this can facilitate and
open up the door
to a completely different way labs can
serve
their system we do a number of work with
safety net hospitals
and you know one of those frustrating
things is when you see the person
who's coming through the er routinely
from a primary care perspective
and so not only is that costing money
but even what's happening when they're
leaving whether you're giving them some
sort of therapy prescription or
otherwise
you may you may find that that's just
not going to be effective
for keeping them out of the er one week
later maybe one day later
and from that perspective being able to
be more
proactive holistic and strategic using
lab data
using some external data resources can
facilitate from a lab perspective taking
a strategic lead for the institution
and guiding the institution in ways to
think about how they can
get ahead of the disease burden and
therefore ahead
of the impact it might have to the
overall enterprise
thank you jeremy now dr hayden let's
come over to you
in your hiv example you were able to
analyze
those patients that were new infections
how did you implement intervention for
those patients
to ensure that they got the right they
to ensure that they got on the right
treatment pathway yeah yeah
it's a great question because like i
said i think there's a very real risk
with universal screening
that all the lab does is incur a lot of
uh you know reagent and labor and etc
costs and not really impact patients
so the way we were able to do this the
answer really is just
michelle rose and and the sdi task force
right
it was having the nurse navigators
having
that connection and so the process is
that
all of these tests are ordered under our
our hospital epidemiologist who's
essential
leader in this effort as well dr schultz
and then
those results flow to nurse navigators
and so we actually have a human being
who is made aware
of any of the positives now importantly
in our laboratory
any of our positive screens are
not resulted out they are reflexed
through the full confirmatory pathway
right
so when they get a positive this is a
patient who has
a confirmed positive
and then those nurse navigators actually
reach out to the patients
and inform them of the diagnosis but
also
of all of the
avenues for care and treatment
you know it's amazing how many times
going to what jeremy was saying that
you know we think of barriers to care
but
something like being able to afford
transportation to doctors visits
is can be a substantial barrier to care
and so having nurse navigators who can
make folks
aware of those resources that are out
there
and to understand what are the reasons
that might keep you from getting on the
care pathway
but so honestly it's a you know the lab
was was one
part in that and connecting the patients
to care
through the nurse navigators and having
that infrastructure
in place was really what made this
actually impactful testing
thank you dr hayden no another question
for you you mentioned you created an
opt-out setting
in your emr for patients how long did it
take to implement the setting
uh i hope nobody would ask that right
it's better when it when it looks so
flawless
um so you know i i have used this
example before
epic and emrs are an awful lot like
amazon they do some things really well
but you really don't have any options
for customization
right try telling amazon that you want
them to to change how their home page
looks or
or click options and things like that
you're not going to get very far
because they know that they need to
build that they need to maintain that
and
epic and the emrs are the same way and
so
while the epic team worked a lot with us
you know they
obviously are hampered and so this is
just a very long-winded way of me saying
over a year with a number of false
starts
as the changes that we made cause
downstream
problems and then we have to stop and
refix
and restart there's potential there
but it's a tremendous amount of work and
not something which is a viable
solution in my opinion um given current
state
to do more broadly
which doesn't mean you can't do it just
for one instance like hiv sorry but
yes no absolutely
now since we're talking about time how
much time do you spend
adding a comment on lab drug
interference
this one has a few parts how many
samples a day
do you do that for and do you still get
calls from clinicians
wanting interpretation of results
yeah that's a good question so the
comments are append so as a great
example you know when we get
an ifu we read through it we will
develop a comment
we append our comments using data
innovations di
and so those are appended
effortlessly on the lab side because
it's the robots
that do that and we will add those
comments as needed or in response
to two clinician comments now that being
said
you know as a good example our beta hcg
has comments on
heterophyll antibodies as well as
pituitary hcg
and middle-aged women and i still
regularly get calls and questions
about those um so
we spend really zero time during the day
adding comments on lab drug interference
we do it for a relatively high number
of samples but i still get a number of
calls which i think highlights that
while the time required to add the
comment is
minimal or zero um
the value to patient care is also
in my opinion uh not terribly high
thank you dr hayden now
let's go with this next question in
certain conditions
it is important to do more than one test
for one condition
or infection in order to not miss some
positive cases to come back
negative how can we push for that
yeah that that's a great one um and
you know it's it's when some things are
negative when some things are positive
right my
my old mentor in seattle jeff bear just
always remind me
that every laboratory test
is a question or a mistake
but typically it's a question right the
clinician is worried about something
and so they're trying to order a test
you know in an ideal world
obviously we would just have them ask us
the question
you know does this patient have
a sexually transmitted infection and sti
and then
we would order the testing as necessary
obviously there's some challenges there
and i think it's essential that we still
allow
physicians to practice medicine since
they have that knowledge
of the patient i think what we try to do
is
to get reflexive test algorithms
approved in advance and those are things
that our physicians
really appreciate
so when they order the test they know up
front it's well documented and clear
them
that's important from some legal billing
implications but
you know they know if this result then
this test
if that result then this other slew of
tests
and that allows them to do the single
blood draw and have the laboratory add
on
so antibody antigen screen is positive
reflexes
you know the antibody conformation
is positive we're done it's negative
you know there are some labs who already
go on to do
the nucleic acid amplification testing
some of those things so it's it's about
having
clearly defined reflex rules which are
approved and make clear to your
physicians and then
in my experience they greatly appreciate
that
thank you dr hayden now we have time for
just a few more questions i'd like to
open this question up to both of you
what went wrong with the covid19 test
of the cdc based of your knowledge
based on your knowledge wow
jeremy you're you're welcome to uh to
represent abbott
on that recorded webinar
yeah i don't i don't have anything i
could say that would feel comfortable to
say about you know kind of
kind of you know what what what when uh
what went against it
from uh you know what was working
against the cdc test
it's i i think that we lose sight of how
complex testing is there is
you know this growing opinion that it's
you know you have a lab vending machine
in the basement i'm not saying that's
that's what happened to the cdc but i'm
saying that
there's so much complexity of what can
happen and
and what can go wrong and
you add in the fact that in my
experience laboratorians
chose to be laboratorians because we
like to have the time to sit
to ruminate to think to search pub
pubmed to speak with colleagues
and then you put us in this situation
where we need to almost act like
er doctors and quickly triage and make
decisions
uh under stress and stressful times it's
it's challenging
thank you both and let's wrap with this
final question this is
open for both of you as well now this is
such a realistic and helpful approach to
the best outcomes however this is
preaching to the choir
are hospital or system administrators
getting this education
yeah so i i'd happy to jump in on this
dr hayden and feel free to
feel free to pile on here give me my
perspective
you know i've been um i've been okay
i've been preaching i guess
this message for i would say going on
almost uh 12 years right um you know
long
you know looking at the healthcare
ecosystem understanding the central
theme of the lab and all the impact
that it can make and it's a really good
question uh what i would say
is you know is is we use the metaphor of
preaching to the choir um it's you know
it's not enough that the message we're
here is is we're delivering is being
delivered across the board
but it's kind of the choir's
responsibility to get people to church
right there's a message in here that
maybe is is
is latent it's not the messages the lab
is valuable
that's not the message that's not the
central theme of the gospel
the central theme of the gospel is a lab
needs to do some different things
to facilitate you know making this
change because we've been saying this
for a very long period of time all of us
collectively
understanding the value that it creates
and talking about it
but at the end of the day talking about
it's not sufficient
and continuing to do what we've always
done and and
and stay under the operating model and i
know this is easier said than done so
please don't take this
as of course this is easy uh staying
under the operating model and the
in the in the in the metrics that we've
been playing from
um yeah is is what's hurting us so
with the call to actions here are a
couple
one is take some time to actually build
a written
strategy for the lab
in a way that's presentable to the
c-suite
so that what you've got is you've got a
way to demonstrate
not not defend the value you're creating
today
but to illuminate the value incremental
value
you could create what the c-suite and
executives and payers
they don't want to hear about how good
they have it they want to hear somebody
step in with solutions that help them
move
forward they create incremental value
and so
you know kind of message one is you know
build
build a strategy a road map an
identification
of where this new value can be created
of where how the lab could be used
differently
and so that's kind of one central thing
the second central theme
is rethink the operating model that you
have
in in terms of you know not only
building a strategy but
but how do you execute day in and day
out uh
what are the what are the things that
you do what are the what are the
activities that you have
uh that enable you to step outside the
four walls of the lab into the patient
pathway
into working directly with clinicians
hand in hand
what are the what are those what are
those behaviors that are different and
new
that increase your visibility and the
third domain
is centered around the tooling and
control as we
just mentioned earlier is is how do you
locate
that those things in your hands i
you know i often joke with people like
i'm horrible at diy
and you know in some kind in some cases
the emr is like
my dad who is a who's a master craftsman
trying to explain
over skype how i'm supposed to put
together a cabinet
now of course he can tell me i can give
me some insight and i can ask him some
questions and you know and he can point
me to the instruction manual
but i don't necessarily have the
tactical skill for it
and so what i would encourage you to
think about is the third call to action
is
try to ensure that you've got the
tooling inside the four walls of the lab
and the lab's control
to facilitate whether that's clinical
decision support whether it's business
intelligence however you want to you
take a look at it
so that you're able to use your data
you're able to access it you're able to
control
for how you look at it uh and you're
able to be in a position
to take an active role with the
executive on the strategy or with the
clinicians downstream
so it's not as much as it is kind of
preaching to the choir and needing the
choir to get people to church
the gospel is slightly different the
gospel is not where valuable we know
that
the gospel is hey let's change let's
build strategy
written strategy aligned to the
executives so that they can see
the value we could create that's
incremental
but let's outline and start to execute
different behaviors that make us visible
that
help us integrate into the patient
pathway side by side with our clinicians
and with our patients
and that third domain is let's tool up
the lab differently
let's make sure that we have control and
we have the tools required
to actually create this value uh and i
know that's easier said than done and i
don't i don't mean to be
you know to make it just oversimplify it
those are real challenges that i know
many of you have tried
but at the end of the day telling people
the lab's valuable
is not going to stimulate any
development or investment in the lab
us acting our way into a new realm of
being
is the only pathway that's going to end
up with people
really genuinely recognizing what we do
i don't know
dr hayden if you have anything more to
add to that or any additional
perspective
i i think it's well said from you
i think the one thing i would add is
that
i always have to remind myself and i
think we as laboratories need to
remind ourselves that it's not enough
to be speaking this message to the
c-suite
we need to speak in a language that they
understand
and what matters to them you know
it's very easy to sort of dismiss
some of the concerns they might bring up
or objections or
um you know to think that you're just
miscommunicating but
really effectively communicating to them
is understanding
sort of you know as jeremy was saying
what are their strategic priorities
what do they value when they look at
something how are they thinking
about it and making sure that you're
doing your best to talk their language
and align what you are doing
in the laboratory with what they want
done
and so you know i think i think it's a
challenging conversation
i think it's happening i think that
there are things both sides can do
to make it probably more impactful but
certainly from the lab
and making sure that you are speaking
their language
and communicating in a way that they
understand and you're aligned with your
institutional priorities um is something
that we can do to better communicate
that
thank you dr hayden and thank you jeremy
both for your
insight on our q a today do either of
you have any final comments for
our audience
just uh thanks for taking the time
especially at a time like this
yeah i would just echo that and thank
you everybody for what you're doing out
there to
make our community safe and get through
this and you know as
we kind of hit on a little bit at the
beginning is you know let's
let's uh let's all keep helping each
other out and uh
we're gonna get we're gonna get to the
other end of this stronger as a
discipline and stronger as a country so
thank you so much thank you both for
today
and before we go i'd also like to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting question
we had quite a few questions we were
unable to answer today
and those questions that we were not
able to answer and any of that come in
during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided
at the time of registration one final
thank you to jeremy shubert and dr
joshua hayden again for their time today
we'd also like to thank libraries and
our sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
mavericks will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
you will now be redirected to the
registration page
for chapter three clinical care
integration
broadcasting live next monday march 30th
at 8 a.m pacific time 11 a.m eastern
time
we hope to see you there have a great
day